Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous raconter les méfaits
de trois chercheurs sans scrupule,
qui ont tenté de duper le public et la science.
Preuves fabriquées, trucage de données,
expériences inventées de toutes pièces...
Tout de suite, voici trois des arnaques scientifiques les plus folles.
Vous allez voir : c'est à peine croyable.
1 - L'homme de Piltdown.
Nous sommes en 1912, à Piltdown,
un petit village situé au sud de Londres.
Charles Dawson, un paléontologue amateur, décroche son téléphone.
Il cherche à joindre Arthur Smith Woodward,
le conservateur du département de géologie, au British Museum.
Dawson veut lui parler d'une découverte qu'il a faite
en se promenant dans une carrière située près de chez lui.
Il s'agit d'un crâne très étrange.
Sa partie supérieure ressemble à la nôtre,
mais sa mâchoire inférieure fait curieusement penser
à celle d'un singe.
Pour Dawson, sa couleur rougeâtre et usée
serait également la preuve
qu'il s'agit d'un fossile âgé d'au moins 500000 ans.
Après une analyse minutieuse des ossements,
les deux hommes en sont convaincus :
ces restes sont ceux du fameux chaînon manquant.
Un spécimen qui serait l'ancêtre commun du singe et de l'Homme.
Et ce n'est pas rien.
Les thèses de Darwin sur l'évolution des espèces
ont bouleversé les connaissances sur nos origines.
Depuis de nombreux scientifiques sont persuadés
que l'Homme et le singe ont un ancêtre commun,
qu'on ne tardera pas à découvrir.
Dawson et Woodward sont donc persuadés de l'avoir identifié.
En décembre 1912,
ils présentent leur trésor à la Société de géologie de Londres.
La communauté scientifique est conquise.
La nouvelle de la découverte de ce crâne,
surnommé l'Homme de Piltdown,
se répand comme une traînée de poudre
dans le monde entier.
On a identifié le chaînon manquant.
Et, ce qui ne gâche rien, il est Anglais.
Pendant 40 ans, la majorité des anthropologues
va se satisfaire de cette version de l'histoire.
Toutefois, certains ont quand même des doutes.
Pour en avoir le cœur net, des chercheurs
de l'Université d'Oxford, décident en 1953
de procéder à des analyses plus poussées du crâne.
Et le résultat est sans appel :
le crâne et la mandibule ne datent pas de la même époque.
Et il y a pire encore.
L'analyse prouve que le crâne est celui d'un homme moderne,
et la mâchoire celle d'un orang-outan.
Les deux parties ont été soudées,
puis vieillies à l'aide d'un traitement chimique.
L'Homme de Piltdown est en fait une arnaque.
Certains pensent que Charles Dawson a été victime d'une farce
afin de le discréditer.
Une enquête est ouverte.
Et dans la liste des suspects, un nom bien connu circule,
celui d'Arthur Conan Doyle, l'auteur de Sherlock Holmes.
Il vivait lui-même à Piltdown,
connaissait bien Dawson,
et était amateur de canulars.
Mais aucune charge n'est retenue contre lui.
Et pour cause, à la clôture de l'enquête,
il est mort depuis plus de 20 ans.
Finalement, en 2016,
une nouvelle étude révèle que l'auteur de cette arnaque
serait tout simplement Charles Dawson lui-même.
Élémentaire, mon cher Watson.
2 - Les souris dalmatiennes.
Aux États-Unis, à la fin des années 1960,
un jeune dermatologue nommé William Summerlin
consacre ses recherches aux greffes de peau.
Il traite les grands brûlés auxquels il prélève des tissus intacts,
qu'il greffe ensuite sur les zones mortes.
Cette opération ne présente aucun risque de rejet
puisque réalisée sur un même individu.
Mais Summerlin pense qu'avec
les nouveaux médicaments immunodépresseurs,
qui permettent d'éviter les rejets,
il sera bientôt possible de greffer la peau
d'un individu sur celle d'un autre.
On est bien parvenu à greffer un pancréas en 1964,
et mieux, un célèbre chirurgien sud-africain
a réussi la première transplantation cardiaque en 1968.
À peine un an plus tard donc,
le jeune scientifique annonce à son tour
avoir réussi son exploit.
Il serait parvenu à greffer les tissus
d'un homme à la peau blanche
sur un homme à la peau noire.
Il en tire aussitôt une certaine notoriété.
Mais le doute s'immisce.
Plusieurs chercheurs ont tenté la même opération,
sans jamais y parvenir.
L'affaire en reste là.
William poursuit tranquillement ses recherches à New York,
sous la houlette de Robert Good,
un immunologiste de renommée mondiale.
On ne parle plus de lui jusqu'en 1974,
année où il fait une nouvelle annonce fracassante.
Cette fois, il prétend avoir réalisé une greffe inter-espèces
c'est-à-dire entre deux animaux non apparentés :
une souris blanche et une souris noire.
C'est un peu comme si on avait greffé
la peau d'un être humain
sur un chimpanzé.
Il présente alors la preuve de son exploit :
des souris blanches affublées
de jolies tâches noires,
des souris dalmatiennes en quelque sorte.
Mais cette fois encore,
l'exploit de Summerlin intrigue ses collègues.
Si bien que ceux-ci s'emparent discrètement des rongeurs,
et ce qu'ils découvrent les laisse sans voix.
Les fameux patchs de peaux noires
disparaissent comme par magie
à l'aide d'un simple coton imbibé d'alcool.
Le petit malin avait en réalité dessiné les tâches
à l'aide d'un marqueur.
Pas de pot pour Summerlin,
cette fois, il est démasqué.
Pour se dédouaner, le dermatologue invoque la pression
qui l'aurait poussé à monter cette supercherie.
En vain.
Il est viré sur le champ,
mais il obtiendra quand même un an de salaire, sous réserve
non pas de faire un pot de départ, mais de se faire soigner.
Aux Etats-Unis, l'expression "painting the mice",
"peindre les souris" en Français,
est désormais devenue synonyme de fraude scientifique.
3 - Le Q.I. des jumeaux
Au début du XXᵉ siècle,
le psychologue anglais Cyril Burt est un personnage très respecté.
On le considère comme le pionnier de la recherche
dans le domaine de l'éducation.
C'est donc à lui, que l'on fait appel pour développer des tests
permettant de déceler les difficultés d'apprentissage
chez les enfants.
Jusqu'ici, tout va bien.
Le hic, c'est que Burt est persuadé
que l'intelligence des êtres humains est innée et héréditaire.
Selon lui, elle n'est pas influencée
par le milieu social ou l'apprentissage.
Et il est bien décidé à le prouver
en procédant à des tests de Q.I.
sur des vrais jumeaux séparés à la naissance.
En 1943, les résultats tombent.
Et ils sont sans équivoque.
Ces jumeaux, qui ont grandi dans des milieux différents,
sont pourvus de capacités intellectuelles strictement identiques.
Sa découverte fait grand bruit
au point d'influencer les politiques publiques
en matière d'enseignement,
tant en Grande-Bretagne qu'aux Etats-Unis.
En Angleterre, par exemple,
on décide d'utiliser les tests de Q.I.
pour sélectionner les étudiants pour telle ou telle filière.
Parfois, dès l'âge de 11 ans.
D'autres vont même s'appuyer sur les recherches de Burt
pour valider des thèses racistes.
Les mauvais résultats de certains élèves issus de minorités
s'expliqueraient par une intelligence inférieure à celle des blancs.
Inquiets par ces dérives,
plusieurs chercheurs se penchent sur les études de Cyril Burt
après son décès en 1971.
Et l'un d'entre eux, Léon Kamin,
découvre que le psychologue a trafiqué
ses résultats sur les jumeaux.
Il avait tout simplement fabriqué des données de toutes pièces
pour obtenir les statistiques qui l'arrangeaient.
Sa théorie sur l'intelligence héréditaire est donc bidon.
Quelques années plus tard,
une enquête du Sunday Times révèle même
que plusieurs paires de jumeaux
étudiés par Burt n'ont tout simplement jamais existé.
Depuis, il a été prouvé
que l'intelligence n'est pas innée ou héréditaire.
L'éducation, le milieu social et quantité
d'autres facteurs
jouent un rôle très important.
La science a également démontré
qu'il n'y a aucun lien entre la couleur de la peau et l'intelligence.
Et voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Bon, je vous rassure, la fraude scientifique reste un fait très rare.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo garantie 100% sans arnaque,
n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous abonner.
À très bientôt,
les Épicurieuses, et les Épicurieux.